are so people have been asking me to
review the Dark Knight Rises Nokia
trailer and I just figured why not just
review the movie it sounds logical the
Dark Knight Rises
are so the Dark Knight Rises is the
third and final chapter to Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy I guess it's
called that even though the first ones
Batman Begins weird and the Dark Knight
Rises is set eight years after the
events of the Dark Knight it's been
eight years since the Joker tried to
burn Gotham to the ground and the whole
Harvey Dent thing you know you've seen
the movie if you haven't really and now
there's a new villain that has shown his
face in Gotham City and that is Bane and
this is Bane's opportunity man he is set
foot in Gotham at the perfect time peace
was achieved and Gotham based on a lie
and I like seeing that at the beginning
of this movie you see how the characters
are still dealing with that even though
it's been a year so it's not like oh
yeah Dark Knight happened now as Dark
Knight Rises Dark Knight does not really
feed into the Dark Knight Rises I mean
it's been eight years how could it know
the people are still dealing with the
fact that they had to cover up a lie
that's what a concluding chapter of a
trilogy should do lead off with the
relevance and momentum Christopher Nolan
does that like a master in this movie
and it was really surprised at where the
characters are in this movie I mean it's
been eight years what's Bruce Wayne up
to what's Gordon up to how are they
doing I just saw and I was like oh
that's interesting I wouldn't have
called that
and now Bane steps into Gotham and Bruce
Wayne's like oh I need to be Batman
again even though it's been eight years
Batman's been m.i.a for eight years he's
really rusty at this point but he has to
put on the cape and cowl and fight Bane
but as we all know there's more to be in
Batman than just putting on a suit he
has to become the Dark Knight and as you
saw in the teaser trailer he tells
Gordon he's like what if he doesn't
exist anymore
and when I say rusty I mean rusty Batman
could take a good look at himself and be
like oh my god
I learned hockey bad Batman taking on
Bane at this point it's kind of like
when you're playing an MMO or an RPG and
you're fighting these guys that are
crazy hard they're all-out level they're
all like these mythic epic elites and
you're like I I shouldn't be here right
now it's like that only Batman has no
choice he can't go a OE grind he just
has to take this on yeah it sucks to be
that day Tom Hardy is bane I loved him
this dude is menacing Bane's mask if you
see it in the comic books his eyes are
covered but in this movie his mouth is
covered and his eyes are exposed that
was a really interesting change for me
but I it worked in this movie because
the expressions
he has in his eyes you're like yeah
that's an intense dude if his eyes were
completely covered up I don't think Bane
would be as menacing as he is in the
Dark Knight Rises saying is undeniably
the biggest threat that Gotham has ever
faced and they do a really good job at
illustrating that he's intellectual he's
physically superior to Batman that's one
of the things Alfred brings up it's like
dude look at this guy you have never
taken on someone like this it would have
been hard in your prime now you're one
rusty Batman The Alfred has to deal with
this stuff too it's like I have a fear
it's not gonna work out for you man
don't do this
man's voice is a funny thing you know I
gave Bane's voice [ __ ] when I saw the
prologue I was like I was kind of hard
to understand in the Dark Knight Rises
he was a lot easier to understand
there's still some times where you're
like um but it's not too bad if for
nothing else you really get the point of
what he's saying you're like yeah he's
getting a little intense and guys are
getting their asses kicked and I got you
pains angry but for the most part I
understood his voice the Bane's voice
for your ears is like 3d to your eyes
yeah when you watch a 3d movie you're
like all right it'll take a minute to
really adjust to this and I'll be fine
that's Bane's voice you hear when you're
like all right it's gonna take a moment
to adjust to this then I'll be fine and
it all works out for it a lot easier to
understand but there will be a couple
times where you're like I didn't quite
understand what he said and I love the
fact that even Joseph gordon-levitt's
character is relevant he's this
idealistic cop he's like if Jim Gordon
and Harvey Dent had a kid Joseph
gordon-levitt and the biggest surprise
in The Dark Knight Rises is a character
that I loved and that is Anne Hathaway
as Catwoman yeah you heard that right
she kicked complete asses Catwoman I
mean in the trailers all you really saw
her do except one axe kick she does to a
dudes head is she talked but there is
more to being Catwoman than talking just
like there's more to being Batman than
putting on a cape and cowl she has the
persona down she's manipulative she's
smart she's cunning she's sexy I really
do mean sexy to she's sexy but she also
kicks ass she knows how to throw down
you put a gun to her face she's going to
snap your wrist and shove that gun up
your ass that's all I'm saying but be
like coughing nine-millimeter bullets
it's going up there and a couple of
times you're like she's like little
Batman she's awesome
I think Anne Hathaway did a great job as
Catwoman and personally I believe she's
the best Catwoman ever put on the big
screen sorry people who like [ __ ]
Michelle Pfeiffer and he and Hathaway
he's just better and more realistic a
couple of times in this movie there are
a couple of what I call quick fixes I
mean there are these hurdles in the
movie you're
oh that's going to be tough to overcome
boom quick fix it's fixed yeah I just
put on this magical robotic knee brace
and now that's done what okay I guess so
and yes this movie's undeniably longest
two hours and 45 minutes you're watching
you're like this is a long movie but at
no point did I ever think to myself it's
too long in fact I would not have minded
the movie being like three and a half
hours long I mean there's a lot that
happens in the Dark Knight Rises as such
they have to move the plot along this
unfortunately means less screen time
with some of the characters we've grown
to love I kick Alfred for example
there's not a lot of alpha in this movie
Alfred is us you know he's our eyes he's
the comedy relief I missed him in this
movie there was not a lot of them made
me sad there's this one scene it's a
situation I would have liked to have
seen that situation be like a half an
hour longer I'm just saying if there is
a director's cut of The Dark Knight
Rises that comes out it's like three and
a half hours long I will buy it with a
big smile on my face other than that
this movie is epic and it goes in
directions that you're not even
expecting you're like I was completely
not expecting that and that is awesome
and if I'm being objective I think one
of the gripes that people might have
with this movie is that they're
unprepared for the directions that this
movie goes I'm just saying people might
be like oh I didn't know it was gonna go
that direction I was unprepared for it I
don't exactly like it and that's not a
negative in the movie that's just a
negative in human nature that's actually
a plus to the movie I could not
compliment the movie more I'm saying
that it's an epic that caught me by
surprise whenever a movie can surprise
me on an epic scale like that by going
in a direction that I didn't even see
coming that's that's never a bad thing
I'm just saying and Bane Pyrrhus I feel
like Bane Pierce are going to be like
actually that's not busy origin story
and I get it but Christopher Nolan in
Batman Begins established that he can
take artistic license with a character
and deliver a badass Batman movie and he
does that in the Dark Knight Rises I
would almost argue that he takes the
most amount of artistic license with
Bane's character that he has in any of
the other characters of his other Batman
movies however the epic that he gives us
vastly outweighs the artistic license
that he takes with the characters if
you're a comic book fanatic that can
just put that aside and enjoy the Dark
Knight Rises as a movie I promise you
you will probably enjoy it I don't know
how promise and probably can go hand in
hand but that's the guarantee I'm a so
the Dark Knight Rises is a really
satisfying conclusion to an epic Batman
trilogy I honestly think this is the
first comic book movie trilogy in which
the third one is also great it's usually
first one good second one good third
and now now we have three solid awesome
tacular movies because the Dark Knight
Rises is awesome tacular so your
favorite Christopher Nolan Batman movie
me they're all great but I prefer the
Dark Knight above the others personal
and this just a personal thing with me
the Joker is one of my favorite
characters of all time I like where
Gotham was is trying to crawl out of the
wreckage of its own damnation and this
unstoppable hurricane is going through
and just slaughtering everyone trying to
make Batman break and successfully
making Harvey Dent break just in terms
of where Gotham was the villain they had
in it and where the characters went in
the movie I thought it was the best
which is another really interesting
thing about the Christopher Nolan Batman
movies they are also great yet so
different they touch on different
aspects and they have such different
tones that if someone's like oh I like
this one the best I can't ever argue
them someone likes Batman Begins the
best great Dark Knight fantastic Dark
Knight Rises I get you I mean really
that is how a trilogy should be Batman
Begins The Dark Knight or The Dark
Knight Rises what is your favorite
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more